so yeah i messaged derek you messaged
derek i miss derek after all these years
i mean i got so excited by this news i
had to just let him know how i felt
tell you none of the topic oh
get off me yeah i couldn't
i couldn't help myself so today's topic
derek jackson
okay derek jackson apparently he's got
himself in some hot waters i believe it
was uh tasha k
yes uh she made a live stream saying
she's gonna expose derek jackson
she had some information and basically
she brought a young woman who claimed
that derek jackson
uh around the 4th of july instead of
being with his wife was with her
and that they cheated and obviously this
kind of news is a big deal to some
people because considering jackson's
propensity towards
commitment to talking about men or you
know sometimes very disloyal and all
these kind of things the rhetoric that
he says and oftentimes men feeling like
yo this guy's trying to sell us out
people are very excited ooh derek
jackson is cheating i'm gonna try to
summarize as best i can the girl and
derrick have known each other for a long
time
i guess basically she was under the
assumption that derek was separated from
his wife so when they met together
things went down and then fast forward a
few months later he said he doesn't want
to see her anymore
she gets mad he blocks her and then she
starts he starts posting about like you
know i'm staying with my wife i'm making
her work blah blah blah
and she felt like yo you're a liar
you're this and that so she put she made
a whole instagram page i saw this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] was wild she had all these
posts and receipts like their
conversations
and people were like yo this is proof so
yeah i messaged derek
you messaged derek i missed derek after
all these years i mean i got so excited
by this news i had to just let him know
how i felt
tell you none of the top oh
petty ass trash ass mess
you
oh you cold
oh i'm i'm actually jealous i didn't do
it
he wrote black man don't cheat
get off me yeah i couldn't
i couldn't help myself you text him yeah
black man don't cheat
wow i'm actually jealous i didn't do it
that's pretty much the reactions you see
it i'm like
derek took it too well he put a laughing
emoji said tell your channel we're good
and the truth is coming very soon
so he's actually still with his wife and
they're talking he says she knows about
everything she's right beside him
and that they're fine tell your channel
we're good me like us
and him no like we're not good i'm just
kidding him and his wife
him and his wife man on the face of it
you could think of it one way
and you know like you you guys me
personally i'm not a fan of derrick
not me not well you are but i think
that's irrelevant when it comes to the
discussion because at the end of the day
what's true is true and being innocent
until proven guilty
still matters to me in the court of
public opinion or in the court of law
and from what i gathered there's nothing
to show really that this person cheated
now maybe him and his wife were
separated at the time people go through
separation periods where they say i need
time apart
you go see somebody i'll go see somebody
and we'll see how we feel
people go through those periods you
don't know what's going on in people's
private life where you just jump to the
assumption
that they are cheating or doing
something wrong or whatever
you know so if you don't have all the
information to come up to some kind of
conclusion based off of little stuff
to me seems very it's dangerous
and uh it's misguided i understand that
people want him to be guilty
because of how he talks because of the
things he says
but don't let that cloud you in regards
to what is right or wrong
don't go based off your desire to hate
him to go in with the bias
that he has to be wrong because that's
how you condemn people who are
oftentimes innocent
that's for how black people come in with
their biases
and then from there any information that
may confirm it is immediately taken in
and any information that doesn't confirm
it is discarded so there has to be a
good balance in a good middle ground
even though it's a harassment even
though it's a hot ass man
it's really that's the hot ass mess and
it looks juicy and everything and stuff
like you said it's like we really want
that person to be guilty right
yeah and it just it just shifts the
whole boat it rocks the boat
right it rock it rocks up the waves are
coming
aaliyah rock the boat rock double i
understand that
right but it was not even that i'm like
whatever like why do i
i don't care i don't care it was just to
me the message it was i was done with
me derek because the message was
disingenuous
at the beginning i didn't need that
situation to be like oh
you see no i didn't need
all of that nonsense it was just a
message
itself right after the message and you
know you say like oh she got mad and
then after that she
exposed all that but she kept that
all that time so it was like an
insurance it was like an nk [ __ ]
people come to you sometimes
and they're ill-intentioned yep they
slide in your dm
that's why you slide in the dm and you
send
you sand news and stuff most likely
we're going to block you
because we don't know what every time
someone slide in and be like oh
this and that and we should i'm like who
sent you
what's the setup what's the trap you
understand what i'm saying
and instead it's just i'm yes you want
to expose him but you kept
all that to expose him yeah while
everything was nice and dandy so you
played the game fair that's okay
but it just shows you it comes and shows
you that it's not everybody that comes
to you
that talks you all nice and everything
and stuff and all that
that that that shirt sugary stuff that
they be telling you
and delivering you that they actually
want some good for you
yup when things pop off and feelings
change
people often seek for revenge it's crazy
kevin hart didn't he get exposed
for cheating by a friend yeah they try
to extort him for money that's a friend
imagine what strangers are willing to do
we've even done videos on this channel
where i've told you guys stories of
people doing shady stuff and i caught
them
so it's one of those things where i get
why people want this to be true but
understand in endorsing that and pushing
that narrative
you're also encouraging a culture where
deceit is rewarded i'm not saying this
girl's inherently lying
she may really believe that derek did
something shady and she could just be
wrong she doesn't know
absolutely that's also a possibility so
we we don't know it's
a bunch of gray areas that's right
that's the real that's the real 50
shades of grey right here
yup it's gray areas everywhere we're not
even
blaming her or shaming her because on
her side
there's also her perspective maybe she
feel
like she was cheated or something i
think that's what i wanted to come to
guys you don't have all the information
and we want to feel like we know what's
going on but oftentimes we don't
because we're not privy to things that
are happening behind the scenes just
because someone comes out
with this story about somebody doesn't
mean that they're right in fact there's
a couple of points in there
where i could easily say you were wrong
so one point she says in 2016
derek sent me this video or he's asking
about my panties and that so
at the time derek was single he wasn't
with his wife at the time
so while in your head you guys are like
that's the smoking gun
all it really is it's evidence that he
was flirting and he's hitting on you
you know and the tough thing about lies
is that when they're masked with some
truth
it makes everything sound credible or
sometimes it goes the opposite direction
yeah so just be careful when you guys
are hearing these stories to just be
like
that's what you are because sometimes
you're never going to hear the full
truth
or sometimes that should come out things
go on for so long and by the time the
real
story comes out you've already moved on
you already have that perception
of that person so do not believe
everything you see online it was like
2016 right uh-huh so
till now and that thing like that thing
happened now right
right yeah it's four to five years
it's four to five years in the four or
five years have we been doing this
channel
there's been ups and there's been doubts
yes or no
that's true it was not always this easy
there was a beginning when we were just
like dabbling with this we didn't know
what we were doing
getting things out and everything and
stuff there's
and there was downs it was like 10 times
that was really hard and difficult we we
even
we were putting ins and stuff like that
in the satan
in the same amount of time and that's
with any relationship
it's never always yeah good good good
good good good good good good good good
good good good
it's not bad there's ups and downs so
from the beginning to 2016 to whatever
happened the fall
it was not always you were not always on
the same you didn't have the same energy
what i know though is that you kept them
receipts
but even that doesn't mean anything but
even the fact that she kept receipts is
shady
here's what i say here's what i'll say
shady i'm sleeping with you and while
you're in bed you're snapping pics
of me where i'm not looking does that
not strike you as shady yep
why would you do that in a situation you
feel is perfectly consistent in some in
some
in some situation that would be a breach
of consent
wouldn't it because yes the person is
with you but it doesn't mean that he
consents of being
his pictures been taken without him
knowing
then after that see it's not receipts
until you return the goods
understand what i was saying it's not
receipts until you return the goods
but snap to me snapping pictures without
people knowing
taking without people knowing super
shady but then again
it's not receipts until you return the
goods but you don't return the goods
so there so as long as you like he's
shady
we could say that you're shady too but i
understand we want him to be wrong yeah
we we
at the end of the day guys you just have
to keep the same energy whether someone
you like or don't
always lean towards the side of what is
true and
that's what we try i've defended amanda
seals when she said some right things
and i'll defend this person as well
if what's happening seems shady i don't
care i
don't care who the individuals are what
matters to me the most
is what is the truth and right now
there's not enough to say this is true
or this is true so
to just run with that narrative seems
dangerous so that's why we want to even
if it is true
my problem is not whatever he's doing in
his backyard or anything
and stuff is the narrative of what he's
putting out there he's always going to
be that
so to me it's not relevant but
it's a hot dumpster trash like it's a
hot mess and a dumpster fire
and a train wreck and a car crash that's
right so i don't know how a train fits
in the car but i'll figure it out we're
gonna figure it out so that's it man
listen
we could have easily dunked on this
would have been one of the easiest
dunkable videos but
you know you gotta you gotta shy away
from it that's not what we do that's not
what we do that's not what we try to do
no no we try not to do so just wanna let
you guys know if we
ever feel like you would come out with a
view you don't agree with or you feel
like it's wrong
also think about like just maybe we saw
it differently could we could be wrong
but don't think we come on here trying
to lie or do anything
for cheddar because honestly if we want
to make money there's a lot of videos we
could have done up until now that would
be way more profitable than what we're
doing
yeah so um just want to let you guys
know that and that's pretty much all i
got not a
it's not a it's not a hot take it's not
a oh we trying to get that [ __ ] it's not
that
it's not we're trying to have we're
going to have a hot take and a hot
narrative
to make people click but that's not what
it is that is
not what it's never been that i think
it's strange i'm happy that you think
it's cringe
and we've never been doing that we never
try to do that
so if we disagree it's because we
disagree but we want to talk about it
that's it that's it that's it so that's
all i got
hot ass mess black men don't cheat
you you're black you're a piece of [ __ ]
for that
black men don't cheat him at the end
right now
[Laughter]
today's video it is five in the morning
spicy if you guys aren't aware you call
me out at five in the morning
five in the morning and i'm yawning
where's that from i don't even know it's
a really bad rapper
and he's got giant ass lips and i think
he's light-skinned
oh i know pretty ricky
pretty rough in the morning